- Wow, you don't seem like an only child.
- I never would have guessed,
you're just so good about sharing food.
- I have to get my niece
something for her birthday.
She's an only child, I can't
get her a board game, right?
Who's she gonna play with?
- That explains why you have
such an active imagination.
- You must love being alone.
- You must love being around people.
- Your parents must have treated you
like the center of the universe.
- Was it hard making friends?
- I bet you had a lot
of imaginary friends.
- Oh you're an only child?
That makes a lot of sense.
- You must be really
close with your parents,
like you're best friends, right?
- Didn't you wish you
had a sibling growing up?
- Why didn't your parents
want any more kids
or oh, is that too personal?
- You're one of the good ones.
- What's wrong with your parents?
Or is that too personal?
- You're so lucky you never had to share.
- I wish I was an only child.
- You're not even self-centered.
- Were you lonely?
- You're gonna have to
take care of your parents
all by yourself when you get older.
That's gonna be really tough.
- I bet you talk to yourself a lot.
- You just seem so well-adjusted.
- Oh but you at least you
get all the best gifts
at Christmastime, right?
Only children are the devil's children.
It's true though.
(upbeat music)